all right he survived the joy Diaz
experience you know I got it I got a um
I got a text from Tom Tom Segura Tom
right yeah I said because he asked me we
were backstage about to go on stage at
the main room and he's like I want to do
my podcast blah blah blah and I'm like
awesome and then we were texting just
about my schedule at him and then he's
and then I'm like okay I'm going to go
see Joey Diaz that and he's like dude
[ __ ] gummy bears watch out and I'm
like what are you talking about I didn't
like I didn't understand what he was
talking about like I didn't you know I
mean I did honestly didn't like I was
like whatever I don't know you're
talking about and then once I got there
you know I smoke weed sometimes you know
I don't smoke all the time but I like to
smoke weed sometimes but but as far as
the edibles I'm like Dean Gelber is like
giving me some like pot stuff but like
cookies and [ __ ] but then like he was
eating his gummy bears and they're in a
bag and I was like going [ __ ] okay and
he gave me just like he gave me just
like an ear or some [ __ ] and that was it
and then I was just like talking them
and then like literally I I couldn't
talk anymore I couldn't talk you a part
of it by a half of one when I had the
lung I had to leave he's got some that
are like 500 milligrams which is just
insane so you probably had half of that
which is like 250 which is [ __ ]
insane that's an insane amount of weed
but I believe in OG yeah I had but I had
done mushrooms once before when I was
younger and it felt like that
yeah well that's to the risk of
repeating myself over and over again
which I do all the time but when you eat
marijuana its processed by your liver
and it produces something called 11
hydroxy metabolite it's a totally
different psychoactive substance that's
four to five times more psychoactive
than THC so that's why it hits you like
that and that's why people think they
got dosed because when you smoke pot the
the the 11 is not psychoactive but when
you eat it it's processed by your liver
something called a one-pass and that's
how it produces that yeah and I can't
believe he let me drive home
like seriously I mean exited like
because when I was driving home I was
like dude I got to go like I stopped
that guy can't answer your questions and
I said let's I have to go and I left and
I drove out and he like he let me drive
like you don't understand Joey Diaz
found his mother dead on the kitchen
floor when he was on acid when he was 13
he would let you fly a [ __ ] plane on
those things he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
just like you'll forget about [ __ ]
anyways so when did it hit you like you
did the podcast like how Helicon playing
do it 15 minutes into it and I couldn't
speak I had to stop like I couldn't
speak did never release a podcast I
don't know I think he did the audio but
not the video oh I told him not to do
the video I couldn't answer any question
yeah but wouldn't that be funny yeah I
guess I don't know I would like to see
myself that [ __ ] up where I can't even
talk mmm yeah those are those edibles
are [ __ ] terrifying
they're not um telling them like they're
like you know these different kettles or
some [ __ ] he's a different type of human
well there's a lot of those people now
because edibles and marijuana has been
legal for so long there's so many
medical patients in California that you
get these people that have insane
tolerances and they're just doing dabs
and eating cookies and Jesus just go
down oh you know the whole marijuana
movement and that whole thing is so much
different different than when I was
growing up you know when I grew up we
still like you know smoke it we go to
the beach and we'd put a towel over us
we'd hide it now like like last night I
was at the the Funny or Die party and it
was I was a tenth anniversary and I was
just walking around just smells like
weed everywhere yeah it's just very
normal now like you know that like I
don't know that's just the way well I
think it's good because like drinking is
normal you know you walk by the bar the
Comedy Store you see a bunch of people
having a blow-dryer this is all wrong
with that it's all good yeah but thanks
for having me my pleasure
yeah I'll try
[Applause]
[Music]